[MUSIC PLAYING]
BARACK OBAMA:
Fighting this disease
had to be a national
security priority.
INTERVIEWER: In the
middle of this village,
we have Ebola victims.
And there are two or three
here, these women and their baby
daughter and another
man just down the road.
And they are all believed
to have the virus.
They're just being left here.
CECILIA ROUSE: The overall
goal of the Modern Plaques
Conference is to bring
together many people
from many different
perspectives, different fields,
different occupations to have
an important conversation
about global health.
We chose the topic of Ebola,
not to necessarily just focus
on Ebola, but
because it provides
a lens through
which we can discuss
many of the critical
issues facing many aspects
of global health today.
CHRISTOPHER
EISGRUBER: There have
been a lot of conferences
on the Ebola crisis
on some of the public
health issues related to it.
This particular conference
is different in that it
takes an interdisciplinary
view of the issues
and brings to bear a broad
range of disciplines.
History, economics, policy
science, political science,
molecular biology,
draws them together
and draws not only on academics,
but also on policymakers
from NGOs and from government.
KEITH WAILOO: I think
one of the lessons
that previous health care,
global health crises,
can teach us is the omnipresence
of overreaction driven by fear,
misunderstanding, confusion,
and the imperfections
of our political processes.
ADEL MAHMOUD: We were
caught unprepared,
unprepared to detect
a disease happening
in a new area with
strong features.
We had no drugs.
We had no vaccines.
We had really very little
public health measures.
ANGUS DEATON: Anything you
might do is going to cost money,
and that money has to
come from somewhere.
I think the simplicity
that when people
are in trouble, if you throw
money at it, that will fix it.
We know that, that's
not really right.
JANET CURRIE: We like to
think about the crisis being
over when people
stop falling ill,
but as we're
discovering survivors
have a range of problems
that are going to be
with them for a long time.
From what we know from a
variety of other circumstances,
children who are impacted
by this type of disaster
will bear long-term
effects, and that
should be kept in mind when
thinking about to aid them
down the road.
AMANEY JAMAL: The takeaway
from this conference
will be the macro perspective
on how epidemic diseases are
conquered and how effective
policies are designed,
but you'll get a perspective
from a historical perspective,
a political perspective.
You'll get a sense of how
the science and the health
care behind this or the
health research behind this.
You get a sense of the cost
underlying these responses.
So the nice thing about this
conference is that in one place
you'll have all
these conversations,
all this engagement and social
engagement, that will be useful
for scholars and
[? policymakers ?]
in terms of how they think
about the spread of epidemic
diseases.
And to have that world view
of all these moving parts
in one place is why this
conference is so valuable.
[MUSIC PLAYING]